what's up fellow geekos we have the
Naruto X boruto Ultimate Ninja Storm
connections premium collector edition
that's a mouthful and let's just see
what's on the side so on this side we
have the logo down here and on the other
side I oh yeah it's just the end of the
Box let's turn to the back real quick
and as you can see there's a whole bunch
of stuff here a lot of digital content
everything down here so we have the main
game we have collectible cards in-game
items and skins costumes accessories and
let's see what else we got we got an
exclusive scroll which is like a you
know a poster got a steel case a
reversible inlay and of course we have
Naruto and Sasuke figurines inside with
the main game so without further adoo
let's just open this up oo oh that's
nice and compact in there that's a lot
of stuff let's just pull this out real
quick and get the main game and the
steelbook out all right so okay so you
have the CD on the inside you also have
the early purchase bonus content which
is a lot of
costumes and let's let's see what else
inside okay there just codes and safety
warning all right oh okay and this is
the special reversible inlay that
they're talking about on the inside so
let's just open that up so this is how
the back looks like let's change it up
to the special reversible
inlay
oo all right a lot of key moments a lot
of special characters you you can see
from here all right this is the special
reversible in there you got a lot of
crowd favorites on here here and this is
pretty much how the main box look like
and on the inside this how it look like
after that so this is something special
for the Naruto fans out there honestly
the last time I had a reversible inlay
was like BioShock Infinite when buying
physical copies from the store was a
thing and let's get to the steel
book all right as you can see a lot of
Sheen and obviously you can see the
separation between the matte layers
which on Naruto and Sasuke and obviously
and of course the effects from The Sword
and his ring gun are all glossy and
sparkly check the back you just get this
so when you open it up oh there's stuff
inside wow okay look get to this Le on
so the back looks pretty much just like
this so the back looks like this and on
the inside what you're getting is this
this is a very sick piece of key art
that they have going on down here with
Sasuke Naruto so let's just get onto the
cards that came out of the steelbook so
the back of the cards look like this
Ultimate Ninja Storm connections Naruto
exporo all the good stuff and you have
Naruto we have Sakura we have Sasuke we
have baruto we have Sara and mitsuki so
these are all the characters you're
going to get mainly you know the main
three protagonists of the Naruto and
boruto lineup they're kind of like MTG
quality with a bit more gloss and they
feel a bit better than some standard
Falls that you get so these are pretty
sick Collectibles that you have so let's
just get into the rest of the box and we
have quite a bit inside there let's just
open this up there something here which
I believe is a scroll all right so here
is the scroll let's open this up nothing
else in the back here and get you let's
open this
up ooh and this comes in a nice soft
packaging let's open this
up
and okay oh it's a really nice look at
that that this is actually sick
wow look at that this is this proper
wood it's not plastic at all it looks
like it came out right out of the show
so wow so this isn't actually like
fabric it's a blend let's open up the
scroll and
wow look at that and honestly this looks
pretty good in person as well you can
really pick out the different groups
very easily in all the different
factions within Naruto again the quality
is really good so if you guys want to
hang this up somewhere or you know frame
it up I I honestly wouldn't put it past
you this thing is actually a really SI
collectible before we continue the
unboxing this channel is supported by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stick around for
this sponsored message here geek culture
we've tested plenty of chairs but Secret
Life gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this mix of fourman
function helps the Titan Evo 2022
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co all right what's coming up
next are the
figurines so very Hefty figurines if I
may add okay so the both of them come in
this box over here the B Presto
figurines Naruto and Sasuke exclusive
figurine sets over here with his Chidori
and wrestling gun let's check the back
very nice packaging very sick and of
course you know it's Sasuke and Naruto
on the side over here so let's just open
her up so for this box it opens up from
the front over here so let's kind of
flip this open I believe here we
go okay and let's open this
up okay so they come in full I believe
oo very nice let's take them all out
nicely they've put everything in pieces
so you got a it's a bit of assembly
required for all of them so that's
that's pretty nice some interactivity
with the Statue not like other statues
that already come assembled so you got
put a bit of work into it which means
you like it even
more okay so uh let's start with Sasuke
and now with the FAS cuz this guy so
again you're getting like collector
edition quality you don't expect
anything like XM or like hot toys but
you know what like the surpris are
getting you at with all the other stuff
you're getting two figurines on top of
everything else and the main game so I
think this is a pretty good deal just
like that very nice there's no
articulation for the legs arms and hit
it's a it's a stationary statue but at
least you know you have a bit more fun
just kind of like putting everything in
so like this kind of slot it in there
it's all push fits all right and then
the back here we're going to be
attaching this thing to his butt so it's
angle like this like is sort of 45°
angle and then I'm going to put him
right here just like that so it's it's a
pretty cool pose I say so myself it's a
pretty cool pose all right so this is
how the wrestling gun hand looks like
it's pretty sick and obviously you know
there's a little thing here to put in
this other SWR for the wrestling gun so
I'm just going to put that right here
kind of slots in like that so it's a
it's a huge piece actually it's a lot
bigger than Sasuke Chidori which which s
right cuz again this guy we have his
upper torso over here he looks really
good of course hand man and after that
we're going to push his lower torso and
legs inside here his little his little
nothing can be seen here as well going
putting some detail shots on that and of
course we're going to be putting his
ring gun on his hand just like
this just just like
that all right and just going to
reattach this real quick flimsy it's a
bit hard to push inside as well it's not
exactly that it doesn't go that deep in
through the wrestling gun ball so let's
just try our best to put it in there
honestly super good will help it's
really not sticking man oh yeah see how
easy that is to come off oh my gosh okay
that is all right you guys definitely
need super glue for this thing so we're
going to put this bit into his cough
right here and then I'm going to slot
him in so
right just's push him right
there just like that all right and look
at these two they're coming for you look
at that double trouble guys yeah that's
that's really all there is to it there's
a lot going on in this box and let's
just talk about the figurines real quick
so this is how the completed Sasuke
figurine looks like I mean I do like it
quite a bit it's lot of Sheen nothing
really looks out of place and there any
like weird lines or anything or more
lines and at the back the chi logo looks
really good the shine and gloss is
really nice but I'll just say that the
little bit of branding down here does
kind of take away from the whole figure
I kind of wish to put it like maybe
somewhere on the inside down here where
it's less visible but it is what it is
right it is what it is and Naruto looks
really good it's just that his hand
placement over here I mean it's
obviously quite accurate to how he's
like in the show when he's running these
ring guns but like if you want to POS
him like this all you're going to get is
this obviously so you kind of have to
POS him to the side just like that which
also kind of takes away from the
wrestling gun because this huge piece is
right here and you can't really see much
of the ball but besides that he looks
great as well just take note of this
whole posing thing over here so
obviously between the two I really like
Sasuke's more Dynamic POS cuz he's
really just coming down from you kind of
Stomp you with his Chidori and Naruto is
just running at you with this machine
gun having these two figurines in the C
really makes the C worth getting I
believe especially with the rest of the
stuff that's inside there you know what
let's just lay everything out all right
so that's it for the Naruto X boruto or
Naruto boruto or Naruto by boruto I
don't know if you guys follow the hunter
hunter logic let me know in the comments
below let me know which title sounds
better to you but anyway this is the
Naruto X boruto Ultimate Ninja Storm
connections premium collectors edition
and there's a ton of stuff there's a lot
of value I believe inside this collector
edition because you've got skins you've
got two figurines you got the main game
you got collectible cards a steel case
and of course not forgetting the special
reversible inlay found in the disc case
so with that follow us on all of our
socials right here to keep upate with
everything we put out we post stuff
daily and if you like what we do on this
channel make sure to hit that like
button and subscribe but then it goes a
long way in helping us out so have a
good week and I'll see you guys
soon
d